when it's time to tank up this car the
driver hasn't got a lot of choice in the
Ruhr region and that's because he needs
hydrogen and this is the only public
hydrogen pump in Dusseldorf the anatole
we manufacture gases so we're interested
in all possible uses for our products
this is a new application for our gases
so we're involved even if it isn't
profitable yet but we can see a
potential if the number of hydrogen
driven cars Rises that'll give us a new
business area annoying the Sheffield his
employer the French company air liquide
has invested around six hundred thousand
euros in the hydrogen gas pump the state
government spent around the same
hydrogen technology is still in the test
phase the small series produced by
Mercedes cost a fortune it says not
really its industry it's all pretty
covered up like it often is this car has
the advantage of a skateboard chassis so
it's all built in underneath you can't
see much just the normal battery and a
compressor but the rest is underneath is
Ananda born
the French company supplies the special
fuel from a facility 50 kilometers away
the plant at marvel is a huge labyrinth
of pipes and tanks it's the third
biggest chemical site in Germany
protective clothing and special gas
sensors are required at the le keyed
site many of the products are explosive
and toxic addition me park my
infrastructure here Marlys fantastic we
receive a concentrated form of hydrogen
here compressed to 310 barnett simba I
don't understand what Khalifa then we
Piper to this low temperature absorption
chiller lager there it undergoes
additional fura fication before we make
it available at fuel quality so Phyllis
then the mall site is the largest
producer of tanked hydrogen in Europe
the French company chose the location
for a good reason not on this far north
rhine-westphalia is one of the important
centres of the chemical industry in
Germany many of our customers are based
here so we have our production sites in
the region as well for example here in
MA
a lot of the local chemical and
pharmaceutical manufacturers use
hydrogen but before the gas becomes
established as a fuel unless duran
fernandez will have to overcome a lot of
challenges and akeed carries out its own
scientific research but it seeks advice
to there are plenty of universities and
scientific institutes in the region that
are happy to accept industry
Commission's at the zbt fuel cell
research center scientists are trying to
make hydrogen technology greener that's
the only way it can keep up with
electric motors this is a moment not at
the moment it's not that green because
the hydrogen still comes from fossil
sources it's generally manufactured from
natural gas using chemical processes the
aim is to make hydrogen by splitting
water with the help of electricity and
to use electricity from renewable
sources like wind or solar power was
unfolding with some cotton a full tank
is enough to drive 400 kilometers but
not all of Germany is covered with a
supply network doesn't know nice gunston
no we aren't that far yet maybe it'll be
easier going south we could get to
Frankfurt or stood guard but we can't
get to Berlin or hamburglars nany chess
Lawson in two years there will be 50
hydrogen pumping stations across the
country and then it will be possible to
drive a hydrogen powered car from the
roar to the capital